really really game-changing reporting
from the Washington Post the actual
first United States coronavirus death
was on February 6th why does this matter
we were told we believed up until
yesterday that the first American
coronavirus death was February 29th in
Kirkland Washington State it's not true
we've now learned that the first
coronavirus death in the u.s. was
actually the 6th of February that's more
than three weeks earlier than we thought
our first case that we know about was
January 20th now in all likelihood the
true day of the first case was much
earlier than that let's just do the math
together we now know the first death was
February 6th in Santa Clara California
ok we also had a February 17th death in
Santa Clara California
both earlier than the official
previously known case both of these
people died at home they were
posthumously tested for coronavirus and
they tested positive so here's why it
matters the entire timeline is different
of the outbreak and of our understanding
if the first death was actually February
6th number one we don't know how these
two people became infected they got it
from someone if one person died on
February 6th and typically it's taking
17 days for people to die for lack of a
better term they probably had their
first symptoms on January 20th with a 2
to 14 day incubation that means that
this person likely contracted the virus
anywhere between January 6th and 12th or
something like that that means that we
had infections in the country in early
January
public health officials so far are
saying they believe this person was
infected in their community because
their travel history doesn't suggest
that they were somebody who brought it
back early from China or another country
so that means someone else had it in
California in early January or even in
late December secondly this is important
because it implies that a lot of early
2010-2020 rather
what's called ili influenza like illness
and influenza like illness death was
misdiagnosed as flu or as primary
pneumonia not caused by Kovac 19 or
other respiratory disease so the second
reason this is important is a bunch of
deaths believed to be flu or other
things in January in February some of
those were likely coronavirus deaths as
well so that the death toll is likely
higher than the official one and number
three this is really important because
we talked about models we talked about
contagion models case models death rate
models something that's really important
for epidemiologists is when did this
start that hugely affects models and the
curves that we anticipate if this
actually started weeks earlier than we
thought it implies way more people have
it today than we think and it has
wide-ranging implications and I've
mentioned this before my girlfriend had
a respiratory thing in mid January it
never got super serious flu was ruled
out it lasted more than two weeks in
retrospect it could have been mild
coronavirus we had just come back from
Europe towards the end of her having it
I got it when I mentioned this to people
a month ago a lot of people dismissed it
said David you're being alarmist there
was no kovat in the u.s. in mid-january
in late January in early February when
you had it and everybody who gets it
gets a fever well we now know there was
kovat in January wheat because someone
died on February 6 we know a ton of
people never get a fever did she have
kovat 19 did I I have no idea but it
doesn't seem outrageous that a lot more
people than we believe have had this now
that does imply a far lower fatality
rate that's a good thing but it implies
it's much more contagious than maybe we
believe we won't know until we have a
reliable antibody test reliable being an
important word there so a very important
report in that we hear January 20 we had
one case and February 29 we had the
first death someone died on the 6th they
had it in January they hadn't traveled
meaning they got it from someone else
there was almost certainly coronavirus
in the US
in early January maybe even in late
December or earlier will we ever know
that that that specifically I don't know
how much more we will know but this
certainly points in that direction let
me know what you think I am on Twitter
at D Pakman and I would love to hear
from you let's take a quick break so
much to talk about today and stephanie
kelton will be joining us once again if
you ever feel like you just don't have
enough time to read all the books you
want to read you have to check out one
of my favorite apps called blinka splink
a' stakes thousands of popular
nonfiction books and distills each one
down into an e-book or audio book that
you can get through in just 15 minutes
where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book just imagine how
you'll be able to expand your horizons
and knowledge by being able to soak up
all of the important insights from 10
different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you can use it
to revisit a book you've already read or
use it to preview a book before you buy
the full version and read it I recently
read a brief history of time of course
by the great Stephen Hawking this is a
book that I have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video